Moin Leute!
Keck Browse
Wie?
Mein GIF geht nicht.
Mein GIF ist kaputt.
Das sollte eigentlich das Keck Browse GIF sein.
Was ist da los? Sekunde.
Keck Browse.
Ach weil es WebP ist.
WebP kann das glaube ich nicht.
Und wisst ihr was noch schlimmer ist?
Das FFM-Pack seit Jahren
kein WebP
in GIF
sorry, sorry
konvertieren kann.
Keck Browse.
Schauen wir mal kurz
ob das
WebP abspielen kann.
Nein, das kann kein WebP.
WebP ist broken.
Broken AF.
Was ist da los? Warum?
Da muss ich
ein
Das gibt es nicht als GIF.
Ist das hier vielleicht als GIF?
Ist das ein GIF?
Das ist ein GIF, oder?
Keck Browse.
Sekunde.
Jetzt müssen wir jetzt checken, ob das ein GIF ist.
Keck Browse.
Es ist ein!
GIF!
Funktioniert.
Hendrix,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Keck Browse.
Ohne Scheiß, die Hälfte
der Emotes sind bei uns Keck Emotes.
Also auch meine Overlays.
Keck Browse. Keck Alu.
Keck W. Keck Wait.
Keck Love.
Keck W mit Mütze auf.
Keck Wait.
Original Keck W.
Ich muss sagen,
0 3 D und 0 ist etwas
unterrepräsentiert hier.
Dabei
muss ich sagen, eigentlich
im Herzen muss ich sagen,
0 W ist immer noch das beste Lachen-Emote.
Dein Drucker ist kaputt.
Ja, Laserdrucker kaufen.
Dann hast du nicht diesen Scheiß
mit Tinte.
Kein Gamescom-Event gemeinsam.
Ist das jetzt? Moment.
Ich dachte, das ist erst morgen.
Mal ganz einfach abgesehen,
das Gamescom-Event ist eh Resident Sleeper.
Guck ich mir nicht an.
Erfreuen wir uns lieber
ein paar schlecht geschriebene Stellen anzeigen.
Oder wollt ihr das Gamescom-Event gucken?
Dann geh ich wieder auf, keck und spiel Runde weiter.
Baldos geht.
So, dann machen wir den ganzen Krempli erstmal wieder zu.
Zack, zack, zack, zack.
Zack.
Package Update.
So muss es sein. Zack, alles weg hier.
Zack.
Kein Gamescom-Event.
Find ich auch.
Gamescom geht mir so am Arsch
vorbei mittlerweile.
Ich war ja da ein paar Mal und das war auch ganz cool.
Wobei es mir die letzten
1-2 Jahre richtig auf den Sack geht und
deswegen bin ich auch nicht mehr hin.
Was die Experten zu den Anforderungen sagen.
Welche Anforderungen?
Willst du uns eine Stellenanzeige schicken und wir sollen drauf gucken?
Schick her,
wenn du irgendwas hast.
Moin Max, was hast du für ein Abschlussprojekt gemacht in der Ausbildung,
wenn ich fragen darf?
Das darfst du fragen.
Ich hab das nämlich schon öfters erzählt.
Ich hab ein eigenes Video zugemacht, falls du das noch nicht kennst.
Kennst du meinen YouTube-Channel?
Sehr free.
Ich vermute mal, weil viele sind von YouTube da.
Aber nicht alle.
Also,
wenn du es genau willst,
wenn du es guckst auf YouTube, ansonsten erzähle ich dir das jetzt.
Weil die Leute keinen Bock auf Gamescom-Event haben,
wie es ausschaut.
Ich hab gesagt, ich kann auch aufgehen und Baldur's Gate 3 weiterspielen.
Chico, was ist denn jetzt los?
So, ich bin wieder da.
Also, wo bin ich stehen geblieben?
Kannst du einen 4K-Monitor empfehlen?
Nee, ich hab selbst keinen 4K-Monitor.
Ich hab einen 4K-Fernseher, aber keinen 4K-Monitor.
Ja, also, Abschlussprojekt.
Was hab ich gemacht?
Frage ich mal andersrum.
Was hast du dir denn so vorgestellt?
Was hast du dir denn schon so ausgemalt?
Aber ich erzähle dir erstmal, was ich gemacht hab.
Ich hab ein VPN gebaut.
Und zwar ein Layer 2 VPN.
Für die Telefonanlage.
Also, eigentlich war das nur ein Beiprodukt,
dass es für die Telefonanlage auch geht.
Ein Layer 2 VPN.
Aber, letztendlich ist es gar nicht so wichtig,
dass du ein super kompliziertes Projekt machst.
Also, rein von der technischen Seite aus.
Das Projekt muss nicht kompliziert sein.
Du musst dich nicht mit technischem Tiefgang beeindrucken.
Bei der IHK.
Die wollen so ein paar Punkte sehen.
Und das wissen viele Leute nicht.
Beziehungsweise haben sie sich nicht irgendwie schlau gemacht.
Weil,
du musst dich mit technischem Tiefgang beeindrucken.
Weil, du musst dich mit technischem Tiefgang beeindrucken.
Weil, du musst dich nicht mit technischem Tiefgang beeindrucken.
Weil, du musst dich mit technischen Tiefgang beeindrucken.
Sondern, du musst für die IHK,
das machen, was die IHK sehen will.
Und das ist, ein bisschen Technik,
ein bisschen BWL.
Das heißt, am besten ist,
du denkst dir irgendwas aus,
was du gerne machen würdest.
Sagst dann aber nicht,
dass du das genau machst.
Ja, das ist genau das.
Genau das, das ist richtig. Das, genau so musst du das machen. Richtig, das sage ich auch in meinem Video.
Ich habe ein paar Videos dazu.
Also, ich glaube...
Hallo Leute. Ich glaube,
wo ich die Story von meiner Abschlussprüfung erzähle, ist hier. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob ich dort was zu meinem Abschlussprojekt
erzähle, genau. Musst du mal gucken.
Schade, dass das Venice Unleashed abgekackt ist als Projekt, ey.
Battlefield 3 ohne, ohne
diesen Blauschleier und mit ein bisschen anderer Beleuchtung teilweise, war so mega nice.
Hat sich so gut gespielt. Leider hatten die ein paar Memoryleaks und haben sie nicht gefixt und haben auch die letzten Spieler sind abgehauen.
Ja, schade.
Ja, also das ist, das ist gut, wenn du das, wenn du das machst so. Also du musst eine Produktauswahl machen. Das finden die
mega gut. Ich meine, müssen wusste nix, aber ich habe auch eine Produktauswahl gemacht. Am besten ist,
du weißt schon, was du machen willst und rein
zufällig
gewinnt dann das, was du eben machen willst in der Produktauswahl. Aber,
also denk nicht, dass du es jetzt komplett, also besser sogar anders gesagt, du solltest das nicht übertreiben. Also sprich,
wenn du eine Produktauswahl machst, heißt es nicht, dass du zusätzlich noch einen finalen, produktiven Aufbau dieses Produkts machen musst. Ja,
du kannst ja im Rahmen der Produktauswahl durchaus mal zwei, drei Testinstallationen
vortäuschen. Du musst das ja nicht mal wirklich machen. Das muss halt danach aussehen, als hättest du es gemacht.
Und danach kannst du, wenn es dir dann immer noch nicht ganz reicht vom Umfang her, kannst du ja irgendwie
noch was weiteres mit der Testinstallation machen. Zumindest
es ist nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache, dass du im Vorfeld halt schon irgendwas Fertiges hast. Aber du kannst natürlich beeinflussen. Das heißt, wenn du,
wenn du PRTG, Nagios und CheckMK miteinander vergleichen willst, und du willst schon mal jeden, du willst schon mal, also,
ich weiß ja nicht, was willst du denn, das gewinnt?
Wenn du willst, dass PRTG gewinnt, sagst du ganz einfach, Anforderung ist Windows.
Beziehungsweise, du sagst nicht, Anforderung ist Windows. Das wäre nämlich Three-Head, wenn du sagst, Anforderung ist Windows. Du kommst zu dem Schluss,
am Aus-, am Ende der Produktauswahl,
dass
Windows in eure gesamte Systemlandschaft einfach besser reinpasst. Und deswegen wird es PRTG, falls du da Bock drauf hast.
Ist ja, ich, ich, ich würde ja lieber den Job wechseln, anstatt, dass ich PRTG machen müsste, auf Windows-only, aber das ist natürlich was anderes.
Wenn du jetzt
Nagios und CheckMK vergleichst, na ja, da kannst du PRTG schon mal gleich raus-, rausstreichen, weil nicht Windows.
Stimmt, Check-, du, du hast recht, CheckMK, ja, du hast recht. Ich glaube, ich glaube, theoretisch läuft sogar Nagios und CheckMK
beides unter Windows.
Stimmt, ich, ich, ich glaube sogar, dass es geht, wer auch-, wer auch immer von allen guten Geistern verlassen ist und das macht.
Ja, umgedreht, wenn es Linux-mäßig sein soll, dann gibt es ja nur die zwei, da fällt PRTG flach.
Was, was willst du denn, dass es wird? Jetzt, ich kann euch das an der Stelle übrigens auch nochmal sagen, also ich habe ja meine Abschlussprüfung gemacht,
mit einem Projekt, wo ich ein Layer 2 VPN aufgebaut habe und ich habe auch so eine Auswahlmatrix gemacht,
mit, ähm, OpenVPN-, boah, was war es denn nochmal? Ich weiß es gar nicht. IPsec, OpenVPN,
keine Ahnung.
Es waren mindestens drei Sachen, ich glaube sogar vier. So, die habe ich über-, die hat-, die Sachen habe ich halt gegenübergestellt und habe ich
Plusse, einfache Plusse, doppelte Plusse,
neutralen Minus, Minus und so verteilt in der Tabelle.
Am Ende kam dann raus, dass, oh Wunder, wer hätte das gedacht,
OpenVPN gewonnen hat. So, und dann habe ich mit OpenVPN noch so eine Testinstallation
gemacht, ob das denn auch so wirklich dann funktioniert. Und da muss ich mich jetzt mal outen an der Stelle,
ich habe mein Abschlussprojekt gar nicht so umfangreich gemacht, wie ich es in der Abschlussdokumentation und auch in meiner Präsentation dargestellt habe, ja.
Ich habe viel weniger gemacht, als ich letztendlich da wichtig getan habe in der Doku zu,
aber
da geht es gar nicht so sehr drum.
Wichtig ist, dass du weißt, wovon du redest, dass das ein überzeugendes
Projekt ist, hat das über-, wahrscheinlich haben das die wenigsten.
Lerne gerade Docker Multistage Build, das ist ja echt Bock.
Ich frage mich, was es da groß zu lernen gibt. Du schreibst halt anstatt einmal Docker Anweisung, zweimal Docker Anweisung
in dein Dockerfile und das Letzte ist das Image, was rausfällt.
Oder was gibt es da groß zu lernen?
Homogenität
des Netzwerks sicherstellen. Da hätte ich jetzt absolut keine Ahnung, was du mir damit sagen willst. Also
als IHK Prüfer. Ich meine, ich kann mir schon was-, ich kann da schon was reininterpretieren. Du willst halt, dass das-, dass euer Netzwerk
so mehr oder weniger so gleichartig aufgebaut ist, ja.
Bisschen laut die Musik, oder? Was ist denn hier los?
Ja, besser.
Ja,
was auch der Grund ist, warum ich privat keinen Bock auf CheckMK habe. Und ganz ehrlich, ich habe jetzt auf meinem-, in meinem aktuellen Job
ein bisschen CheckMK kennengelernt, weil die da noch eine ganz, ganz
altgediente-, also nicht von der Version her, aber die gibt es schon lange.
Alt-, altgediente CheckMK Installation hat noch nicht, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Also
irgendwie ist alles Monitoring Kacke, ganz ehrlich.
Das, was noch am erträglichsten ist, ist, wenn es um Metriken geht, finde ich es Prometheus.
Wobei, in dem Bereich gibt es tatsächlich sogar ein paar ganz brauchbare Sachen. Aber diese Oldschool Monitoring Sachen, es ist alles irgendwie Kacke.
CheckMK fühlt sich an wie von 2005 irgendwie.
Dann hast du-, dann hast du Zabbix. Zabbix an sich ist eigentlich ganz cool, aber unglaublich ressourcenhungrig und
dann gibt es noch Oldschool Nagios, was es ja in der Variante gar nicht mehr gibt, neu. Dann hast du
gibt es sonst noch so Sensu und so Zeug, was Kassau benutzt.
Es ist alles Kacke.
Ich finde, das Beste, was es gibt tatsächlich, ist Prometheus, aber Prometheus ist halt nicht unbedingt dafür gemacht, so dieses klassische
Monitoring zu machen. Du guckst von außen, dir eine Kiste an, ist die Up oder Down?
Das geht alles, aber du merkst, dass das halt viel selbst gebastelt ist.
Prometheus ist richtig geil zum Metriken einsammeln und dann irgendwelche Graphen mit Grafana drüber machen.
Aber alles andere ist halt wie das Monitoring-System selbst gebaut.
Achso.
Nee, nee, mach dir Monitoring-Auswahl. Monitoring-Auswahl, das ist ein sehr-, das ist eine sehr gute Projektidee, mach das. Monitoring-Auswahl.
Monitoring-Tool-Auswahl, du musst aber ein bisschen Technik machen, einfach nur, einfach Produktauswahl. Also du kannst ja drei-,
zwei oder drei Testinstallationen machen. Nimmst dir drei Tools, machst eine minimale Testinstallation.
Du musst dir halt noch Kriterien-, also das ist ja-, so eine Produktauswahl ist ja nicht so einfach gemacht.
Du musst dann nicht nur am Ende bewerten, du musst dir am Anfang auch noch erklären, nach welchen Kriterien du das Ganze auswählst.
Dann gab es irgendwelche Showstopper, bla bla bla bla. Du kriegst das nach drei Jahren wahrscheinlich auch easy hin.
Ja, aber nee, mach das, mach Monitoring-Auswahl. Das ist ein super Abschlussprojekt.
Also du musst natürlich, wie gesagt, Produktauswahl mit so-, mit drei-, drei Testinstallationen und dann bewertest du das Ganze.
Das ist vom Umfang her gut, das ist von der Mischung aus BWL-Shit und Informatiker-Kram gut und ist vieles drinne, was die IHK sehen will.
Kannst dich schon mal darauf einstellen, dass du in der Abschlussprüfung gefragt wirst, sagen sie mal, auf welcher Schicht des OSI-Modells operiert eigentlich CheckMK?
Da denkt man sich dann nur, was ist das für eine bescheuerte Frage? Ergibt eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn, aber so Fragen kommen dann immer dran.
Wurde dir auch was zum OSI-Modell gefragt in der Abschlussprüfung?
Was ist das denn, DeadEye? Zeig mal her, was haben wir denn da? Können wir uns gleich angucken.
Ich hab nämlich noch gar nicht angefangen.
Musst du auch hin und wieder mal neue Kollegen einlernen? Nee, die müssen mich einlernen gerade.
Obwohl ich finde, das Einlernen hält sich eigentlich in Grenzen. Ich bin jetzt seit fast 4-5 Monaten da. Runden wir mal die Woche auf.
Und außer die ersten paar Wochen hielt es sich doch echt stark in Grenzen.
Das liegt aber auch daran, dass ich zum größten Teil glücklicherweise an der ganzen internen Sache vorbeikomme, weil ich hauptsächlich Google und Cloud mache.
Äh, Moment.
Du kannst die doch auch einlernen aus dem Homeoffice.
An den ersten paar Tagen soll gefälligst euer Chef da sein, dafür sorgen, dass die ihr Notebook, ihren Arbeitsplatz und sonst was kriegen.
Und ansonsten könnt ihr euch ja abwechseln.
Ihr könnt ja einmal die Woche Ansprache vor Ort machen, so die Sachen zusammen zeigen. Das haben wir auch alles Remotes über Teams gemacht. Überhaupt kein Problem.
Also wenn ich vor Ort dafür sein müsste, würde es mich auch abfacken.
Ansonsten habe ich das eigentlich immer ganz gerne gemacht, weil ihr kennt mich so. Ich rede halt manchmal ganz gerne über Zeug, was mich interessiert und dementsprechend fand ich es auch immer gut, wenn mir dann einfach Leute 3 Stunden am Stück zuhören mussten.
Salto, vielen Dank für den Sub.
Danke an die ganzen anderen Leute, die ich schon übersehen habe. Übrigens Leute, ich habe gesehen, irgendwie ist das bei Twitch sehr merkwürdig, ja?
Wenn ihr hier am Start seid und euch gefällt der Stream...
Nein, ich will euch nicht schiebäden zum Subscriben. Das könnt ihr natürlich auch machen, weil das ist ja bald wieder erster, ne? Und so. Ne, das wollte ich gar nicht sagen.
Wenn ihr öfters dabei sein wollt, wenn ihr euch das Ganze gefällt, könnt ihr auch einfach followen.
Weil irgendwie ist Twitch komisch, ja?
Ein paar Streams im Folge geht es dann hoch, teilweise bis zu 15, 16 Follows per Stream.
Und dann mache ich mehr oder weniger genau das gleiche, genau in die gleiche Richtung die nächsten paar Streams.
Und die sind dann ein bisschen plus und teilweise minus. Ich verstehe die Twitch-Logik nicht so genau, aber das heißt, wenn euch mein Content gefällt, wenn euch der Stream gefällt, wenn ihr mir gerne beim Schwätzen zuhört, beim Basteln zuguckt, dann könnt ihr mir auch an der Stelle followen.
Und neben dem, dass es für Twitch nice ist, dann freue ich mich auch drüber.
So, musste ja gerade mal in den Stream-Manager gucken.
Gut.
Reagierst du noch auf den Gamescom-Livestream? Ne, das juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Ich gucke mir vielleicht mal eine Zusammenfassung morgen an.
Aber, ganz ehrlich, Gamescom, was war das letzte wirklich coole, was auf der Gamescom angekündigt wurde?
Ähm, damals, es gab neue Overwatch-Sachen.
Und das Jahr davor gab es, wie hieß diese World of Warcraft, das World of Warcraft-Add-On mit den Demon Hunters?
Nicht Shadowlands. Shadowlands war das, was alle kacke fanden.
Ähm, ich spiel kein WoW, deswegen hab ich das schon wieder vergessen.
Legion? Das kann sein. Ja, Legion, das mein ich.
Genau, das wurde dort angekündigt.
Und das war tatsächlich ganz cool.
Wisst ihr, jaja, das war ja auch noch zu Zeiten, wo ich auf der Gamescom war, natürlich ist das alt.
Also, ich muss sagen, da hatte ich echt Glück.
Das war wahrscheinlich noch so das und Overwatch-Neuigkeiten.
Das war wahrscheinlich noch so der letzte Hauch, den man mal live bei so einer Veranstaltung von Blizzard spüren konnte.
Wie die Fanboys abgingen und die Atmosphäre, das war schon cool.
Ich glaube, heute gibt's da kaum noch was übrig.
Ja, gibt's da kaum noch was übrig von Security-Awareness.
Was willst du denn da für die AK-Prüfung machen?
So, ich schule Leute, dass sie keine USB-Sticks anstecken sollen.
Was ist eurer Meinung nach ein guter Einsteiger-PC, mit dem man schon was machen kann auf Low-Budget-Niveau?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich hab keinen krassen Geheimtipp, aber...
Also, willst du selbst bauen oder willst du fertig kaufen?
Weil, was ich ganz gut finde, was ich mir für eine Emulator-Gaming-Geschichte...
Hä?
Ja.
Was ich mir für eine Emulator-Kiste zusammengebastelt hab, also fertig gekauft, so ein Teil.
Ein UM690, den gibt's auch noch in kleineren Ausführungen.
Und der ist natürlich leistungsmäßig auch enorm gut.
Grafisch gut, also für das... Das ist mehr oder weniger das gleiche, was in der PS5 drin ist.
Naja, nicht wirklich. Ist schneller als was in der PS5, aber vom Stil her so ein bisschen das, was in der PS5 drin ist.
Hat aber eine bessere CPU.
Das ist nice, das ist zwar jetzt nicht das Billigste, aber wenn du sowas Kleines, Kompaktes haben willst, was ordentlich Wumms hat, sind die Dinger nicht schlecht.
Aber ganz ehrlich, für den Preis kriegst du sicherlich auch schon was deutlich Besseres, gerade wenn du selbst zusammenbauen willst.
Ja, ist auch alles Mist.
Firewall-Monitoring in Prometheus, das ist gut.
Das ist auch ein gutes Abschlussprojekt.
Man muss bei der IHK allerdings immer gucken, dass man halt...
Du musst halt ein bisschen BWL und...
...Business-Gramm mit reinkriegen.
Sonst kann's dir halt passieren, dass die IHK es gleich ablehnt.
So, dann gucken wir uns das jetzt doch mal an.
Du musst das OSI-Modell auswendig...
Moment, das OSI-Modell auswendig? Ach du Scheiße.
Also was ich mir nur immer merken kann ist, please do not throw salami pizza away.
Oder war das so?
Please do not throw salami pizza away.
Doch, ich glaube, das war das.
Das heißt, okay, Chatgy, lass mal kurz überlegen.
Das OSI-Modell von unten nach oben, also von eins bis sieben.
Physical?
Oh, den zweiten kann ich mir immer nicht merken.
Das ist halt...
...Wi-Fi und Ethernet und sowas.
Die Data-Link oder sowas.
Das ist Data-Link-Layer.
Also Physical-Layer, Data-Link-Layer.
Network, Transport, Session, Session 5, 5 ist Session, genau.
7 ist Application.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was 6 ist.
A.
Ne.
Please do not throw salami, P.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was der sechste Layer im OSI-Modell ist.
Presentation-Layer.
Kacke, Mann, ey.
So ein Schrott, Mann.
Hättet ihr alles gewusst?
Hättet ihr alles aus dem Kopf gewusst?
Jetzt kommt der Chat natürlich wieder und sagt, ja, Max, selbstverständlich, ich weiß das alles.
Natürlich.
Layer 8 ist der Vermonitor, ja.
Hat Monitoring als Thema und als Frage dann SMTP, ach, ich habe SNMP gelesen.
SMTP und Frank zu API-Smile-Integration im Ticketsystem.
Ja, die saugen sich teilweise bei der Abschlussprüfung richtig schades Zeug aus den Fingern.
Weißt du, was mit dem Wort von Sonntagabend passiert ist?
Du meinst Svelte?
Ja, den habe ich gelöscht.
Ich habe IP-Leaked und ein paar andere Sachen.
Aber wenn du was Spezielles wissen willst, dann kannst du natürlich fragen.
SaltoFreak, Dankeschön für den Sub, Leute.
Pog.
Exzellente Subscription.
Oder wie es mein Englischlehrer früher gesagt hätte, Subscribation, Subscribierung.
Der war ja wirklich der Meinung, dass Subscription auf Deutsch Subscribieren heißt.
Dann subscribiert mal.
Ja, habe ich ja gerade schon beantwortet.
Follower, Follower.
Gagbusiness.
Wir können dein...
Ich lasse mich in...
Lässt du dich auch in Exposure bezahlen?
Wir können dein...
GitHub-Projekt bewerben.
Wo kann ich am besten Python-Entwickler Senior-Level zur Festanstellung finden?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich wollte es gerade sagen.
Mach dir einen LinkedIn-Account.
In Deutschland ist Xing auch recht beliebt, aber LinkedIn ist eher the way to go.
Mach dir einen LinkedIn-Account und schreib, du bist Senior-Python-Entwickler und schreib halt ein bisschen Zeug rein.
Und das Allerwichtigste bei LinkedIn.
Mach dir...
Mach dir einen Anime-Avatar.
Da kriegst du noch mehr Anfragen.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass LinkedIn sagt, bitte bestätigen sie ihre Identität, das sind sie gar nicht.
Ansonsten war das eigentlich nicht so.
Aber ich habe es die letzten paar Male, wo ich gestreamt habe, gemerkt.
Ich mache exakt das gleiche.
Wir machen das gleiche Thema für vier Streams.
Mit ein bisschen Unterbrechung.
Und...
Erster Stream gibt, keine Ahnung, plus 15 Follower.
Nächster Stream, das gleiche, minus 5 Follower.
So, und minus 5 Follower, der nächste wieder plus 10 Follower.
So ganz weird, Champ.
Gut, mag bestimmt auch ein bisschen an der Zeit liegen und alles, aber irgendwie verstehe ich das System nicht so ganz.
Aber es ist mir nicht so, als würde ich jetzt permanent auf der Statistik gucken.
Ich habe nur letztens reingeguckt und es ist mir aufgefallen, dass es irgendwie sehr merkwürdig ist, wie das schwankt.
Ach Moment, du suchst Leute.
Ich dachte, du suchst einen Job.
Tja, das ist schwierig, Leute zu finden.
Ich meine, wenn du keine Stellenanzeige schaltest, dann wirst du keine Leute finden.
Und ob die Leute gut sind, das musst du ja bewerten dann.
Aber viel wichtiger ist erstmal, dass du eine halbwegs attraktive Stellenanzeige zusammenzimmerst, die die Leute anspricht.
Und vergiss den Obstkorb nicht.
Du kannst natürlich auch hier mal im Chat posten, Gehaltsspanne und Region.
Wir haben ein paar richtige Pfeifen und Pfeifen Leute hier im Chat.
Vielleicht.
Also, ich kann dir eine Sache sagen.
Wenn du ganz gut bezahlst, dann schreib zumindest mal eine Gehaltsspanne mit in die Stellenanzeige.
Das machen zu wenige.
Ich finde, das hat auch einen sehr guten...
Das wirkt sehr anziehend.
Wenn die Leute auch gleich wissen, dass da ordentlich was zu holen gibt.
Video für den Aufwachstreben.
Toxische Welt der Softwareentwicklung.
Ganze 55 Views.
Aber der Tim macht gute Videos, den haben wir schon ein paar mal geguckt.
So.
Ich mach jetzt nochmal schnell den Chat durch.
Die CT hatte letztens sowas auch.
Ja, aber ich glaube, es gibt mittlerweile bessere Möglichkeiten, als sich dafür eine CT zu kaufen.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendwie ein Bild von einem Home...
Was ist HO? Home Automation?
Ist das nicht HA?
Was meinst du?
Home Assistant?
Home Office?
Ne.
Davon gibt es kein Bild.
Mein Schreibtisch ist auch viel zu unordentlich, dass ich das fotografieren will.
Gute Frage. Wahrscheinlich.
Aber schnell ist wieder das nächste.
Dann hast du Glück gehabt.
Also IHK lehnt auch immer ganz gerne Sachen ab, wenn im Vorfeld schon klar ist.
Und das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur, weil ich das random sage.
Also das könnt ihr auch überall im Internet nachlesen.
Also die IHK ist bekannt dafür, Abschlussprojekte erst gar nicht anzunehmen.
Wenn dort essentielle Sachen fehlen aus ihrer Sicht.
Und wenn da gar kein BWL oder zumindest ein bisschen Businesskram drin erkennbar ist, dann lehnen die das auch mal ganz gerne ab.
Vor allem, wenn von Anfang an direkt fest steht, was gemacht werden soll.
Wenn du sagst, ich installiere, keine Ahnung, drei Windows-Server und darauf dann ein Ticketsystem oder so.
Das mag die IHK nicht.
Da hast du Glück. Jira ist noch eines der besseren Ticketsysteme.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde Jira eigentlich vollkommen in Ordnung.
Wie seht ihr das?
Also ich muss sagen, alle anderen Sachen gingen mir bisher mehr auf den Sack als Jira.
Das einzige Problem bei Jira ist, wenn das jeweilige Unternehmen total verkonfiguriert.
Atrix42, gibt's das noch? Wobei das ja der Hersteller ist.
Nein, das ist nicht ernst gemeint.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ein Anime-Bild auf LinkedIn besonders gut ankommt.
Auf der anderen Seite, eventuell, vielleicht hilft es ja auch genau denjenigen anzusprechen, der den perfekten Job für dich hat.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber eigentlich machen sie auf LinkedIn ansonsten alles immer so super seriös.
Und eine Sache, die ich auf LinkedIn ja immer ein bisschen lächerlich finde.
Ich gucke da immer noch bei meiner alten Firma rein, wo ich vorher gearbeitet habe.
Und ich finde es immer geil, dass auf LinkedIn, also auf LinkedIn sind so krass viele Selbstdarsteller.
Ich gucke da manchmal noch rein und da posten dann irgendwelche Projektleiter und sowas.
Ich muss es jetzt anonymisieren, aber so ganz cringige Sachen, so nach dem Motto.
Deutsche Finanzbranche und Top-IT? Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ich selber nicht, aber seit ich bei XY bin, habe ich festgestellt, nicht nur Microsoft und Google können Top-IT.
Nein, bla bla bla kann auch Top-IT.
Das ist so cringe, das zu lesen, Alter.
Also auf LinkedIn habe ich echt den Eindruck, manche posten dann nur irgendwelche Blogartikel rein zur Selbsthuldigung und zum Schleim beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber.
Wurde deine Stelle schon besetzt bei deinem neuen Arbeitgeber, bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber?
Also, ob es meine Stelle direkt war, weiß ich nicht, aber ja, wurde sie.
Allerdings, sie haben niemand gefunden und jetzt haben sie, haltet euch fest, haltet euch fest, gleich klippen, dass ihr Racism posten könnt auf Twitter.
Nee, ernsthaft, haltet euch fest, soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, wurde meine Stelle besetzt von einer Inderin, die kaum Deutsch kann und jetzt kommt der Hit,
die wurde schon gleich von meinem alten Arbeitgeber instant gescammt, zumindest das, was ich so gehört habe.
Nämlich, braucht die ja irgendwie für die Aufenthaltsgenehmigung und sowas braucht die ja einen Job mit einer gewissen Dauer und sie haben ihr versprochen unbefristeten Job und jetzt haben sie den Job irgendwie nur bis Ende des Jahres befristet oder sowas in der Richtung.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das, ob ich das alles, alles richtig mitbekommen habe.
Ich hab das ja auch nur um drei Ecken gehört, aber ganz, ganz weird champig wieder, was da los, was da läuft, ja.
Wahrscheinlich wollten sie die runterhandeln damit, ich hab keine Ahnung, was da läuft.
Ich sag doch richtig, also bei dem Laden wundert mich echt nichts mehr.
Ja gut, dass ich da weg bin.
Auf Xin und LinkedIn schreiben mich mehr Frauen an, als auf irgendwelche Dating-Apps.
Ähm, was schreiben die denn? Schreiben die dann sowas wie, oh, ähm, dein, dein GitHub-Profil macht mich ganz wild oder, oder schreiben die nur, suche Experte, äh, suche Python-Experte, biete 35k im Jahr.
Ah ja, was meint ihr denn, was auf LinkedIn sich rumtreibt?
Da kriegst du teilweise so komische Offer wie, ich hab euch das doch erzählt, von meinem Kollegen, der jetzt auch bei mir arbeitet.
Ich hab euch das doch erzählt, wie sie den versucht haben zu scammen über LinkedIn.
So nach dem Motto, LinkedIn-Recruiting-Typ schreibt ihn an, mach mal ganz kurze, ganz kurze die Story, ja, ich hab die euch glaube ich schon zweimal erzählt.
LinkedIn-Recruiting-Typ schreibt ihn an und sagt, hier, wir suchen hier einen, äh, keine Ahnung, Experten-Admin und Gehaltsspanne 90 bis 105k.
Und da hat er gemeint, oh, cool, klingt gut, da hat er sich dort, hat er sich dort beworben, beziehungsweise der Recruiter hat das für ihn in die, in die Wege geleitet.
Dann hat er mit denen, äh, Vorstellungsgespräch gehabt, er hat mit denen sogar einen, wie nennt man sowas, so einen theoretischen, theoretischen Fall durchgespielt, so.
So nach dem Motto, bei ihnen geht ein Störungsticket ein, es handelt sich um die höchste Störungstufe, wie reagieren sie?
Der, der hat so einen Fall mit denen sogar durchgespielt, die hatten drei Vorstellungs-, zwei oder drei Vorstellungsgespräche, Case-, nee, Case-Study ist, ähm,
ich dachte Case-Study ist sowas, was die, was die Unternehmen machen, um was besser zu verkaufen, so mit Testimonials und sowas, Szenarien, sowas in der Richtung.
So, der hatte zwei oder drei Vorstellungsgespräche mit denen und am Ende, also es, es war immer diese 90 bis 105k im Raum.
Und am Ende waren sie sich einig und so, alles gut, es wurde ihm auch immer wieder bestätigt, so und dann ging's da drum, so nach dem Motto, okay, jetzt lasst uns mal einen Vertrag fertig machen.
Und dann sagen sie zu ihm, ach ja, übrigens, die Stelle, ähm, wir, wir, wir können ihnen nur 75k anbieten, es war leider keine Senior-, keine Senior-Position mehr im Budget vorhanden.
Das Budget ermöglicht keine Senior-Position mehr.
Und dann hat er auch gesagt, okay, kack bye, tschüss, fragt man sich halt auch, was denken die sich denn dabei? Denken die sich, man fängt irgendwo an, die einen quasi schon vorm Vertrag unterschreiben, verarschen, was denken die sich dabei?
Ich versteh das nicht.
Oder, oder meinen die, ah, wenn die unsere Firma erst kennengelernt haben, dann, dann, dann machen die, dann machen die das auch für 30k weniger, oder wie?
Hä?
Versteh, versteh, das werde ich nicht verstehen, ähm.
Selbstgebautes Ticketsystem, der Ticketchamp.
Wird Zeit, Leute.
Hangar, ich, ich such, ich such keinen neuen Job.
Kennst du dich mit SAB Aberbaus?
Nein, ich hab's auch nicht vor zu lernen.
Aber wir haben im Chat ein paar, also falls du Leute suchst, wir haben im Chat, wir machen hier jetzt, äh, Wobblers Stellenvermittlung.
Falls du welche suchst, schreib mal in den Chat.
Wir haben hier ABAP-Experten, hab ich schon gesehen.
Hat, hat eigentlich, wie hieß er denn?
Der mit dem Python-Entwickler, hat der noch was reingeschrieben?
Hier.
Bloß wieder weg.
Was kennst du denn für, für, was kennst du denn so für Firmen?
Bei meiner war eigentlich alles top und an Feinheim wird sich auch gehalten.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, weder deine noch meine Sample-Size sind sonderlich hoch.
Das heißt, kein Eindruck von uns ist jetzt irgendwie repräsentativ für die gesamte Branche.
Bei dir lief alles gut, bei mir lief zum größten Teil auch alles gut.
Außer, dass ich keinen Bock mehr auf meinen alten Arbeitgeber hatte.
Aber, das, das war ja auch nicht von mir.
Ne, muss ich sagen, das mit diesen 90-105k und wir bieten ihn jetzt 75k.
Das war von dem Kollege, mit dem ich jetzt quasi in der neuen Firma, quasi gewechselt bin von der alten in die neue.
Den haben sie verarscht in der Richtung.
Meinst du, der ABAP grenzt schon an Selbstverletzung?
Okay, auf geht's.
Also, das wurde eben geschickt, ob ich mir das mal angucken kann.
Wir hatten das geschickt und ist derjenige noch da?
Weil, ich hab jetzt ja gefühlt 20 Minuten gelabert, seitdem er das geschickt hat.
Wer war denn das?
Äh, D-Space.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, das ist Dead...
Dead Eye?
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist das nicht mehr drin, so lange ist das wahrscheinlich schon her.
Okay, auf geht's.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Ach, Dead Eye.
Wobei, sag's mir nachher, okay?
Wenn ich fertig bin mit...
Weil, wir hatten hier schon Leute, die Stellenanzeigen gepostet haben, aus zwei Gründen, oder sag mal, zumindestens aus zwei Gründen.
Einmal, weil sie sich drauf bewerben wollen.
Oder zweitens, weil sie der Herausgeber der Stellenanzeige sind.
Aber, sag's mir, sag's mir erst danach, ja?
20.10 Uhr, naja, ist halt 25 Minuten her.
Aber es müsste eigentlich noch drinstehen, ne?
Ey.
Warum hab ich eigentlich meine Timestamps ausgeblendet?
Ich find das immer nicht...
Chat-Aussehen.
Zeitstempel.
Ja, es ist nicht mehr drin, dabei.
Die Musik kann sich heute echt nicht entscheiden, welche Lautstärke sie haben will.
Okay, also, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Willkommen bei dSpace.
Start your career.
Softwareentwickler.
Agile.
Excellent.
Da wird direkt diagonal das Skalieren angefangen.
Softwareentwickler, MWD.
Agile-Produktentwicklung.
Oh.
Da hab ich ja gar keinen Plan von.
Das heißt, ich kann da wirklich nur sehr allgemein was zu sagen.
Kennung, Chandon Paderborn.
Männlich-Weiß-Deutsch, natürlich.
Äh, als Softwareentwickler sind sie ein wichtiger Teil unseres...
Okay, bla bla bla bla.
Okay, Configuration Desk.
Also, ich vermute mal...
...das ist was, was dSpace herstellt.
Sie können ihr Gespür für Innovation einbringen.
An herausfordernden neuen Features arbeiten sowie bestehende Funktionalität weiterentwickeln.
Gleichzeitig schaffen sie es, durch ihr sehr gutes Technikverständnis maximale Kundennutzen zu schaffen.
Wir bieten ihnen eine ansprechende Gelegenheit, sich in einem positiven und kreativen Arbeitsumfeld...
Bla bla bla bla bla.
Okay.
Ähm, bisschen Lobreise am Anfang muss sein.
Ihre Aufgaben.
Eigenständiges und Gemeinsames Programmieren mit Kollegen in einem internationalen Scrum-Team.
Wissensaustausch im Team und kontinuierliche Weiterentwicklung der eigenen Fähigkeiten.
Es ist ein bisschen sehr vage alles, oder?
Bis jetzt zumindest.
Vielleicht kommt ja noch.
Konzeptionierung und Implementierung von Features zur nutzerfreundlichen Unterstützung von Simulink.
In unseren Tools sowie Sicherstellung der Produktqualität durch frühes Testen.
Anwenden Agiler Methoden, um anwendergerechte Funktionalität iterativ und inkrementell weiterzuentwickeln.
Oh, da muss ich mal kurz drauf eingehen.
Das war nur ein Witz mit dem Obstkorb, ne?
Das ist so das Meme.
Also, ganz ehrlich, wenn du Pluspunkte sammeln willst in der Stellenanschreibung, in der Stellenbeschreibung, in der Stellenausschreibung, dann schreib rein, mach irgendeinen Witz über den Obstkorb.
Sag, wir haben bessere Vorteile als ein Obstkorb oder sowas und dann das. Irgendwas.
Mach dich lustig über den Obstkorb, das finden die Leute gut, das haben wir als Pluspunkte.
Und kostenlose Getränke auch, ja das ist gut.
Das Ding ist, ich brauche schnell ein paar Python-Entwickler, die bereits das ein oder andere komplexe Projekt abgeschlossen haben und Erfahrung mitbringen.
Erfahrung mit KI wäre von Vorteil.
Gehalt 20k bis 90k.
Joa, da kriegst du bestimmt ein paar Entwickler für.
Wenn du schnell Leute brauchst, ich meine du hast ja im Prinzip nur drei Varianten, wenn du schnell Leute brauchst.
Du kannst entweder dich möglichst attraktiv verkaufen, beziehungsweise dann muss halt auch dein Unternehmen was zu bieten haben.
Du kannst deine eigenen Ansprüche runterschrauben oder du kannst die Leute mit Geld zuschütten.
Realistisch betrachtet wahrscheinlich irgendwie so eine Kombination aus allen drei Dingern.
Also ich denke, für das Gehalt kannst du durchaus Python-Entwickler finden.
Es kommt natürlich immer drauf an, so ein bisschen die Branche und die Region.
Aber ich denke für so, aber so wenn wir uns vielleicht Richtung 90k bewegen, da findest du auch recht schnell willige Leute.
Musst das halt gut verkaufen.
Und Chat, wenn einer Interesse hat, Python-Firefat-Entwickler mit Projekterfahrung und eventuell noch Ahnung von KI.
Dann könnt ihr euch ja im Chat bei HellenicGuy melden.
Wir machen jetzt hier, krieg ich es eigentlich bei dir, verdien ich?
Ich müsste eigentlich auch was, falls wir irgendwie Leute vermitteln, müsste ich eigentlich auch was dran verdienen, oder?
Okay, wir, ich will das andere aber nicht überbrechen, äh, unterbrechen.
Ja, aber schreib, schreib, schreib ruhig mal so ein bisschen, was ihr macht.
Ich meine, Leute, fällt es immer schwer sich so ein bisschen zu überwinden, wenn sie gar nichts dazu wissen.
KI finden bestimmt viele Leute extrem nice und Gehalt von Richtung 90k finden bestimmt auch viele Leute sehr nice.
Also da wirst du, wirst du was finden.
Und ich weiß, dass wir im Chat durchaus die einen oder anderen richtig schlauen Python-Entwickler haben.
Das weiß ich unter anderem daher, weil ich vor ein paar Streams was gebastelt habe in Python und nicht so viel Plan hatte.
Also mich willst du eher nicht haben.
Und wir hatten im Chat einige, die kannten sich richtig gut aus, zumindest so, meinem, meiner Auffassung nach, ja.
Also lass mal weitergucken.
Anwenden agiler Methoden, um anwendungsgerechte Funktionalität iterativ und inkrementell weiterzuentwickeln.
Ja, könnte man doch mal ein bisschen Continuous Integration und Delivery und so droppen auf die, da stehen die Leute doch drauf.
So, also, na klar, ich, ich vermittle euch alle, Leute.
Da müssen, langsam müssen wir mal über Vermittlungsprovisionen reden.
Also, ihr Profil.
Abgeschlossenes Informatikingenieur oder verwandtes technisches Naturwissenschaftsstudium oder eine vergleichbare Qualifikation.
Sehr gute Programmierkenntnisse in MATLAB, Simulink oder C-Sharp und .NET.
Sowie die Bereitschaft sich in die jeweils andere Programmierumgebung einz...
Das finde ich gut, dass das so geschrieben ist.
So nach dem Motto, es muss nicht alles perfekt sein.
Also, mit C-Sharp und .NET, da hätte ich Ahnung von.
Mit, von Math, Math, MATLAB, MATLAB, wie auch immer man das überhaupt richtig ausspricht.
Man wird es wahrscheinlich nicht MathLab aussprechen.
Ähm, habe ich keine Ahnung, hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Gute Kenntnisse in C und C++ von Vorteil.
Na, da wäre DSpace bei mir aber genau richtig.
Ideale Erfahrung mit Microsoft Azure, DevOps, Git, Microsoft Visual Studio.
Ja, okay, passt gut dazu.
Bereitschaft, ein komplexes Produktportfolio zu lernen und Spaß daran,
Herausforderungen in Teamarbeit zu bewältigen.
Ja, okay.
Gute Deutsch- und Englischkenntnisse.
Was sie bei uns erwartet.
Wir haben in einer zukunftssicheren Branche internationalen Teams,
mit dem DSpace Mentoring gewährleistet wir eine zielsichere Einarbeitung.
Wisst ihr, das finde ich auch immer so ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Also, ich gette, warum das viele Unternehmen reinschreiben.
Wahrscheinlich, weil viele Leute auch schon negative Erfahrungen gemacht haben
und festgestellt haben, es gibt keine Einarbeitung.
Aber, ich denke mir im Umkehrschluss immer,
ist das nicht eigentlich das ureigenste Interesse des jeweiligen Unternehmens,
die Leute gescheit einzuarbeiten?
Individuelle Weiterbildung mit flexiblen Arbeitszeitmodellen, sagen wir.
Für eine Work-Life-Balance.
In Kooperation mit Egym Wellpass.
Egym.
Egym Wellpass.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, auf der Arbeit auch.
Das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Habe ich aber nicht.
Einen freiwilligen, monatlichen Netto-Inflationsausgleich.
In Höhe von 150 Euro zahlen wir ihnen zusätzlich zu ihrem Gehalt.
Okay, nice.
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob 150 Euro die Inflationsrate aktuell ausgleichen.
Ich meine, angenommen, man verdient um die 100k,
damit kann man es einfacher rechnen.
Das heißt, im Jahr wird das ganze 10k teurer, alles.
Ungefähr.
Das heißt, dann müsste es eigentlich 1.000 Euro Inflationsausgleich pro Monat geben,
dass das ungefähr hinkommt.
Die betriebseigene...
Das ist sehr gut.
Wenn man sowas als Vorteil hat, unbedingt reintramieren.
Unser D-Space Spirit, bei uns sind alle per Duo.
Dresscode gibt es nicht, was?
Ja, okay, das ist auch schon mal nice.
Und kein Obstkorb.
Okay, bevor ich da jetzt mehr im Detail dazu sage,
Deadeye, willst du dich dort bewerben?
Oder ist das eine Stellenanzeige von euch?
Du bist interessant?
Okay.
Also ehrlich gesagt,
ich finde die sehr 0815.
Da ist jetzt nichts, was für mich
irgendwie sonderlich heraussticht.
Sie könnten...
Es liest sich sehr 0815.
Leider ein bisschen wenig Details.
Wäre auch ganz interessant,
was sie sonst noch für Technologien einsetzen.
Oder vielleicht,
wenn es die schafft,
bekannte Frameworks, irgendwas.
Und keine großartigen Informationen
zum Thema Homeoffice.
Das wäre das Erste, was mir so einfällt.
Natürlich, wenn du Kinder hast,
ist das ein Riesenargument hier.
Die Stellenanzeige ist ja nur noch 15.
Ja, das stimmt.
Leute, wenn ihr übrigens noch andere Stellenanzeigen habt,
sei es von eurer Firma,
wo ihr wissen wollt,
was so ein random Dude auf Twitch davon hält.
Oder wenn ihr euch irgendwo bewerben wollt,
schickt her.
Ansonsten gehe ich jetzt gleich auf StepStone
oder sonst wo und such mal,
was es bei mir in Frankfurt gibt.
Aber wie gesagt,
noch könnte ich,
aber ich habe gar kein Interesse, da abzuhauen.
Weil bis jetzt finde ich da eigentlich ganz gut.
Es juckt mich nicht,
irgendwie da abzuhauen.
Sag mal.
Schick mal eine E-Mail hin.
Deswegen meinte ich ja,
es wird wahrscheinlich eher nicht so ausgesprochen.
Muss man T3-Sub sein?
Um vermittelt zu werden.
Das war ein Witz.
Leute, wenn du einen Job suchst
und jemand im Chat ist,
ich habe kein Problem,
ein paar Worte zu verlieren.
Aber ich habe,
ich bin kein professioneller Vermittler
und habe es auch nicht vor zu werden.
Leute,
nicht, dass ich auch noch in den Insi-Modus muss demnächst.
Das wäre ja,
wäre ja fatal.
Wobei,
der Insi-Modus
ist doch schon wieder out.
Jetzt sind wir noch krasser Trader in Dubai.
Oder in Dubai,
wie die Amis das irgendwie sagen.
Okay.
Warum habe ich denn hier das
Image geöffnet eben?
Was?
Zum Beispiel SAP?
Nee, Leute.
Ich will keine SAP-Jobs suchen.
Wann Halbmarathon?
Ich hätte heute fast
neue Bestzeit gehabt,
so über sechs Kilometer,
aber ich musste dreimal stehenbleiben.
Aber nicht, weil ich nicht mehr konnte.
Zweimal,
wegen Hunde-Gassi-Gären.
Und einmal,
weil mein Handy,
wie nennt man das? Handy-Gürtel? Handy?
Tasche? Handy?
Wie heißt denn sowas?
So eine Tasche,
die macht man sich so um den Bauch.
Oder besser gesagt,
so unter das Hemd,
unter den Bauch.
Sowas hier.
Ist gerutscht, die musste ich einstellen.
Laufen-Handy-Tasche.
Sowas hier.
Laufgürtel für Handy.
Der ist gerutscht.
Louis-Vuitton-Store, ja.
Gürtelstraße.
Frankfurt-Gürtelstraße. Louis-Vuitton-Store.
Zahl die Kollektion bar.
Pick-up-Sponsor.
Einzige Haftbefehl-Lyrics,
die ich bemerken kann.
Ja, so ein Teil ist das.
Der ist gerutscht.
Da stand ich bestimmt 20, 30 Sekunden rum
und hab das wieder enger gemacht und angezogen.
Wahrscheinlich hab ich fast ne Minute
oder länger rumgelaufen
und rumgestanden.
Also ich hab das Handy dabei.
Also ich hab so nen Gürtel
hier in der Richtung.
Hier mach ich nen Schlüssel rein,
hier mach ich das Handy rein und dann
dreh ich das rum,
sodass ich die Schnalle vorne hab
und das Ding hier aufm Rücken.
Das steck ich unter's T-Shirt, das siehste kaum.
Das ist ein ziemlich
labberisches T-Shirt.
Steck ich in die Hose und dann geht's los.
Ich war heute Morgen wieder.
Also ich muss sagen, mittlerweile,
also einen Vorteil hat das auch,
wenn's keine neue Bestzeit gab.
Muss ja nicht immer, geht natürlich auch irgendwie langsam.
Ja, gucken wir uns gleich an.
Also eins muss ich sagen,
ich hab mir letztens ein
wie jogge ich richtig
vom Laufstil her
Video angeguckt
und ich muss sagen,
das hat wirklich was gebracht.
Ich hab das heute mal
versucht soweit umzusetzen.
Deutlich angenehmer,
sowohl für
die Beine als auch
für den Rücken.
Und ich hatte, also ich war schneller
mit bisschen niedrigerem
Puls. Also
das hat sich wirklich
gelohnt, das sich mal
in Ruhe anzugucken.
Ich nehm das Handy mit,
das liegt daran, ich hab zwar
eine Fitness, ich hab zwar so eine Tracking-Uhr,
aber die
also die zeichnen
auch ohne Handy und sowas auf, aber
ich will, dass
man sieht, wo ich rumlaufe.
Das sieht man nur auf dem Handy.
Falls irgendwas ist, ja.
Es ist grad nicht viel zu heiß. Ich bin heute Morgen um 7 Uhr gelaufen.
Da war es noch nicht so heiß. 37.
Oder? Warte mal.
Sag's euch.
Garmin-App.
Ich bin gelaufen.
Um
7.46 Uhr.
Und es waren 20 Grad.
Sieht man da auch.
20 Grad.
Und ich hatte heute
meine
Kilometerzeiten waren
1,9 Minuten 14.
Das war, wo ich 30 Sekunden oder so
oder 30, 40 Sekunden rumgestanden hab und mein Handy
Gurt justieren
musste. Zweiter Kilometer
8,11. Dritter
8,37. Vierter 8,18.
Fünfter 8,6.
Sechster 7,18.
Da hab ich bisschen Gas gegeben.
Also
mein Ziel jetzt erstmal ist,
angenehm so die 6 Kilometer
laufen können, ohne dass es mir jetzt irgendwie
nervig wird
und gucken, dass ich konstant
unter 8 Minuten komme.
Ne, hab ich grad nicht.
Okay, let's go. Also
gucken wir uns das mal an.
Element. Und das da
haben wir auch noch. Okay.
Also. Software
Engineering. Senior.
Salzburg.
Remote. Aha.
Vollzeit. Teilzeit.
Jetzt passt der männlich-weiß-deutsch
Witz gar nicht mehr, weil
Salzburg
ist in Österreich, oder?
Ja, glaub schon.
Spanien.
Wusste ich doch.
Okay. Also.
Männlich-weiß-österreichisch.
Aber ich find schon mal gut,
dass gleich oben drin steht Salzburg
äh nicht Salzburg, äh Remote
und Teilzeit möglich. Das find ich nice.
Das würd mich persönlich schon mal direkt ansprechen.
Okay, worum geht's?
Die Entwicklung von individuellen E-Commerce
Web-Applications im
Business-to-Consumer
und Business-to-Business-Bereich,
wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege, ist
deine Welt. Da bist du bei uns
genau richtig.
Für den Fall der Fälle, dass
ich weiß nicht genau, wer die
Stellanzeige gepostet hat, aber
für den Fall der Fälle, dass derjenige
die Stellanzeige gepostet hat,
die gepostet hat, weil
sie von dem Unternehmen ist, wo er arbeitet.
Ähm.
Ja.
Eternity. Ne, es ist ja von euch.
Ihr sucht gerade. Also ich glaube,
ich gette,
ihr wolltet einen coolen, innovativen
Einleitungsspruch machen.
Aber den hab ich in der Art und Weise,
also jetzt nicht mit Business-to-Consumer,
Business-to-Business, aber der
ist so 0815 der Spruch.
Ich find, ich find es schon mal gut,
dass es nicht anfängt mit
Wir sind die Elements
GmbH und wir sind die geilsten und
einen halben Absatz haben, warum das Unternehmen das geilste ist.
Es gibt schon mal große Pluspunkte, ja.
Aber der Satz ist wirklich ultra 0815.
Den hab ich in der Variante
keine Ahnung, schon 150 Mal oder so
gesehen.
Vielleicht gibt's ja noch irgendwas, was einfach
griffiger für euch ist.
Genau. Nutzt Twitch-Emotes.
Dann findet ihr auch die guten Leute.
Aber kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen Kern der
Sache. Warum seid ihr wie verrückt
am Kack-Business-Spam? Was hab ich verpasst?
Kack-Business?
Kack-Business-Fragezeichen?
Einfach nur so.
Also.
Was wollen sie denn haben?
Selbstständige
Entwicklung von individuellen E-Commerce
Web-Applications. Okay, ja.
Teamorientiertes, aktives Mitdenken bei Entwurf
und Konzeption von neuen Kundenlösungen.
Weiterentwicklung und Betreuung von bestehenden
Lösungen?
Wollt ihr da nicht vielleicht
Projekten, Produkte oder sowas hinschreiben?
Oder Applikationen?
Weil wenn's doch schon die Lösung ist,
muss man sich auch nicht weiterentwickeln, ne?
Management des gesamten Software-
Das Software-Entwicklungs-
Lebenszyklus?
Da fände ich jetzt als Bewerber noch ganz interessant,
was ihr darunter versteht.
Weil mir das Einblick gegeben würde,
wie das bei euch läuft.
Also sprich, bis zu welchem
Zeitpunkt bin ich dafür zuständig?
Bin ich auch für Cloud-Deployments zuständig?
Gibt's ja durchaus Entwickler, die müssen sowas
heutzutage machen, was ich auch gar nicht schlecht finde.
Gibt's irgendjemand,
hat denen ein Kubernetes-Cluster hingestellt
und die müssen ein paar YAML-Files erstellen
und deployen dann ihr Zeug selbst.
Also es wäre tatsächlich ganz interessant zu wissen, was da alles dazugehört.
Entwicklung von
technischen Guidelines
und Qualitätssicherung? Ja, gut.
Passt irgendwo.
Auch wenn ich jetzt
direkt auf Software-Entwicklung
münzen könnte.
Proaktive Mitarbeit an Kernkomponenten
und Frameworks sowie Open-Source-Projekten?
Das ist cool.
Das würde ich tatsächlich sogar mal ein bisschen
weiter hervorheben, weil ich glaube, das macht bei
vielen Entwicklern Pluspunkte.
Wäre vielleicht ganz gut, an dem Punkt
noch drunter zu schreiben.
Sowas wie Elements
ist ein großer Open-Source-Contributor.
Zum Beispiel das und das und das.
Finden die Leute wahrscheinlich auch ganz spannend.
Das hast du
alles drauf. Hervorragende Erkenntnisse in
PHP.
Muss das sein?
Gut, gibt Leute, die mögen PHP.
Sehen wir oft genug auf YouTube, kriegen wir
irgendwelche PHP-Videos vorgeschlagen.
Es gibt tatsächlich erstaunlich viele
PHP-Begeisterte.
Langerjährige Erstellung von Web-Applikationen?
Kann man erwarten bei einem Senior.
Einschläge-Erfahrung
Datenbanken bei RiaDB?
Das ist ja der ganz klassische
Web-Stack hier, oder?
PHP, MySQL.
Gute Kenntnisse, HTML, CSS
und JavaScript.
Guter Umgang mit Linux-Systemen. Interessant,
ja.
Das ist ja wirklich ultraklassisch.
Linux, MySQL,
PHP.
Chat, wer spricht hier von Node?
Es geht doch eindeutig um PHP.
Unsere Tools und Technologien.
PHP-Storm?
Damit macht ihr bestimmt Pluspunkte.
GitLab?
Gulp?
Ist das nicht so ein
so ein
JavaScript-Job-Runner?
Das ist
PHP-Zeug, keine Ahnung. Bootstrap?
Webpack? MonkaS?
Elastic?
Elasticsearch?
HTML5,
Redis, Docker, Git, CSS3,
GraphQL. Ah, okay.
36 Stunden
Arbeitswoche,
kein All-In und keine
Pauschalen?
Da bin ich
jetzt ein bisschen lost, was damit
gemeint ist.
Und keine Pauschalen?
Chat, habt ihr eine Idee?
Was ist damit gemeint?
Hat das was mit Überstunden
zu tun?
Ach so, keine Pauschalen.
Ach so ist das gemeint, okay.
Überstunden, jaja, jetzt verstehe ich es.
Office, Homeoffice
oder Remote?
Ein innovatives Umfeld,
bei dem du aktivieren kannst.
Loyalty-Program, Details zu allen
und Benefits findest du hier.
Das ist halt schon ein bisschen.
Ach so.
Moment, also.
Ich hätte ja gesagt,
das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Und ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das Gehaltsgefüge
in Österreich aussieht,
aber
ganz ehrlich,
für einen Senior-Entwickler
46k
ist jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen wenig.
Also ich meine, für einen guten Senior-Entwickler
kann man auch mal das Doppelte ausgeben.
Also insgesamt würde ich sagen,
ist nicht schlecht.
Ein paar Sachen habe ich ja schon
erzählt, was mir zu einem aufgefallen ist.
Was ich gut finde ist,
dass ihr euch nicht erstmal selbst Lob preist.
Irgendwie in der halben
Seite.
Aber
insgesamt würde ich sagen, es ist sehr
lobenswert von euch
ein
Gehalt
dran zu schreiben.
Ich weiß, das steht ab.
Allerdings
spätestens
seit DSL-Anschlüssen
sind die Leute skeptisch, wenn da steht
ab. Weil die Leute denken,
ah, das ist das Minimale.
Okay, das kann sein, dass das
in Österreich anders ist, aber insgesamt
würde ich sagen, 46k für einen Senior-Entwickler
würde ich jetzt sagen, ist
ein bisschen wenig.
Aber wenn es ein Österreich-Ding ist, dann
ignorier das, was ich gesagt habe.
Ich finde es wunderbar, dass das Teilzeit
möglich ist, dass das Homeoffice
direkt drinnen steht.
Remote, Hybrid,
alles gut. Also ich denke, ihr werdet
sicherlich den einen oder anderen Bewerber darauf
finden. Ich
würde mir halt ein bisschen ums Gehalt Gedanken machen,
aber das ist natürlich, vielleicht ist es ein Österreich-Ding,
dass das eher so ein
weil es gesetzlich erforderlich ist, halt drinnen
steht und keiner achtet wirklich da drauf.
Keine Ahnung.
Einzigartige Arbeitsatmosphäre, flexibles
Arbeiten, Body-System.
Well-Being.
Legendäre
Firmen-Events. Oh, da geht
bei mir gleich der MonkaS hier.
Geht los.
Aber ist ja gut, solange die Sachen
nicht Pflicht sind, kann ja jeder dran teilnehmen,
der Bock drauf hat.
So sieht's aus.
So, und dann hat doch
eben jemand noch was gepostet.
Otto!
Deutscher Otto Lang.
Ist Otto nicht pleite?
War da nicht letztens was?
Ach ne, Otto Grub
rutscht in die roten Zahlen.
Nee, die sind noch nicht pleite.
Die machen nur weniger Geld.
Okay, nee, das ist halb so wild.
Not stonks.
Checkst du nur Entwickler-Stellen? Nee, eigentlich
nicht, weil ich bin kein Entwickler.
Ich bin froh über irgendwas
anderes.
Zu Entwickler-Stellen kann ich nur so allgemeines
Zeug sagen, das ist ja eigentlich mein
Fachgebiet, auch wenn wir erstaunlich oft
Software-Entwicklung machen,
im Stream, aber
das ist nicht, womit ich mein Geld verdiene.
Das ist eine Pen-Tester-Stelle,
da gucken wir uns auch gleich an.
Reply.
Schauen wir uns gleich an.
Gucken wir uns erst mal
Otto an.
Software-Developer, AWS Python.
MWD, Vollzeit, Teilzeit,
Homeoffice möglich. Sehr gut, dass das gleich
drinnen steht. Erschienen
vor sechs Tagen. Gut, ich vermute mal,
derjenige, der das gepostet hat,
will sich dort bewerben, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, wer es gepostet hat, aber
kannst ja mal in den Chat schreiben.
Ich vermute, du willst dich dort bewerben. Ich gehe nicht
davon aus, dass du in der Otto-Personalabteilung
arbeitest. Wobei das
auch witzig wäre, wenn sich die Otto-Personalabteilung
anhören würde,
was irgendein Random-Kerl auf Twitch
dazu sagt.
Wenn das der Fall ist, dann sollte ich wirklich langsam
Consulting-Sachen
dafür verlangen.
Otto ist eines der erfolgreichsten... Okay,
das nervt mich immer ultra
ab. Ich meine, hallo?
Das ist eine komplette Seite
Selbstlobpreisung.
Erstmal am Anfang. Das juckt doch
keine Sau.
Um jetzt mal böse zu sein.
Das juckt doch niemand, Alter.
Ich werde das jetzt skippen.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Mach auch du, Otto, zu deinem Playground.
Wir entwickeln
jeden Tag mit Leidenschaft für den Marktplatz.
Otto.de
Ganz schöner Otto, die Anzeige.
Dinge ausprobieren,
neu denken, innovativ sein,
aber über sich hinauswachen. Das ist unser
Mindset. Richtiges High-Performer-
Grindr-Mindset.
Lasst uns gemeinsam etwas Großes erreichen.
Egal ob du das Campo...
blablabla
in maximaler Qualität
mit voller
Fehlertransparenz und komplett
unabhängig vom technischen Stand des jeweiligen
Partners. Konkret bauen.
Betreiben wir alle User-Interfaces
und Application
und APIs immer
mit vollem Fokus auf die Bedürfnisse
der Partner. Und da wir unseren Service
auf sehr viele Partner und Produkte auslegen,
setzen wir auf eine moderne
Event-getriebene High-Performance-
Architektur.
Da wird
Events gesourced wahrscheinlich.
CQ...
Wie heißt dieser Krempel?
CQRS oder so?
Ist auch so ein Buzzword.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Placing fast.
以RastBackend.
PlainJavaScript.
Ist es WordPress?
Ist es überbleibsel?
Was?
Bundle
ManifestJSon
Mobile
wie heißt dieses ding da gibt es doch so eine ja bild mit sowas in der richtung sowas in der
richtung was wapper leise exzellent scheiß drauf interessiert aber wirklich in was sie das gebaut
haben bombs in was könnten sie das gebaut haben es absteckt bombs im bett ist das react ng ist das
ist das angela also am tech stack das habe ich gesucht das habe ich gesucht alter schlimm war
okay dann ist es dann ist es reaktor ja es ist reakt
fast hier und entseite okay also was suchen sie denn ein software developer mbd microsoft
power platform specialist sie brennen für die programmierung möchten maßgeschneider
der anwälte es gibt auch irgendwo so einen es gibt auch bestimmt schon in den chat bot
in den chat gpt prompt mit dem man solche introsätze generieren kann oder die lesen
sich teilweise so ähnlich sie brennen für die programmierung möchten maßgeschneidert
applikation auf basis der mächtigen microsoft power platform entwickeln genau das ich wache
morgens auf und denke mir auch alter ich würde so gern maßgeschneiderte mächtige anwendung
entwickeln auf microsoft power platform basis und wir wissen mit innovativen dann kommen sie zu uns
zum ausbau unseres agilen entwickler teams suchen wir sie als engagierte wissensdurstige
und vor von den möglichkeiten moderner software begeisterter persönlichkeit jetzt wollen sie es
aber wissen er auf basis modernster programmier spannen was ist das das sind vb 6 noch okay
also zeigt mal her ihre rolle entwicklung innerhalb und mit der mikro was ist denn
eigentlich die microsoft power platform ich habe da so keinen plan von power bi ist das
das habe ich schon ein paar mal gehört und nicht gerade positiv modellierung datenstrukturen
die eingestaltung sie schafft lange ins ok mix eine sache javascript benutzerdefinierte
schnittstellen webentwicklung untersprachen wie sie schab und javascript einfach nur entwickeln
konnten nach den devops prinzipien wie jetzt ihr sucht ein power das ist auch das hat auch
schon ein bisschen zu viel oben drüber wieder oder ein bisschen ein bisschen zu viel anderes
zeug dabei wenn breitstelle eingestellt betreuen von kundenprojekten nach dem devops prinzip
gut sie wäre schon mindestens ein objekt orientierte programmierung praktische erfahrung
bereich der entwicklung berufsausbildung fachinformatiker für andere entwicklung
abgeschlossen studium sind empathisch nutzer hineinversetzen diese sie haben durch was uns
besonders macht einarbeitungsphase offene arbeitsumgebung dass er it club office also
quasi eine art großraumbüro discover the spirit of excellence und derzeit hier ausstattung auch
für mobile office flurry raschin familiäre werte da gibt es einen link zu konur vielleicht
ja ich glaube machst du das öfters ja so einmal im monat also ich glaube so schlecht ist es gar
nicht es ist einfach nur nichts für mich dem entsprechend also ich fühle mich dadurch nicht
angesprochen aber das liegt einfach daran als überhaupt nicht meine themengebiete sind es ist
jetzt nicht super ja überragende stellenanzeige wo ich sagen will geil da ist aber hier die
bewerbung raus wie gesagt ich sowieso kein job aber ich habe auch schon weit schlechteres gesehen
zu der microsoft geschichte kann ich halt nicht sagen dass ja und finde ich dann vielleicht ein
bisschen viel ja auf der einen seite suchen sind entwickler aber jetzt soll er auch gleichzeitig
noch irgendwelche devops und betrieb machen und kundenprojekte organisieren aber der rest
geht glaube ich voll in ordnung wir haben outlook auf der arbeit ich benutze outlook nicht ich habe
einfach text files mit meinen notizen drinne fertig und wenn ich outlook benutzen muss dann
nach möglichkeit web outlook ok ein einkommen zu angucken oder weil momo wenn du wenn du schnell
bist können wir das heute noch machen also zehn minuten hätte ich noch zehn minuten können wir
noch schnell mit uns angucken dann würde ich jetzt da würde ich jetzt also wenn du wenn es
die schon gibt ja ansonsten machen das nächsten monat ich meine nichts das muss nicht nächsten
monat sein es kann auch sein dass ich in zwei drei wochen der meinung bin da jetzt könnte man
wieder bock drauf haben wir dann hier ein ok schon mal eine angenehme seite was ohne darkreader
nicht nicht komplett blendet dm kuppel ein linux systemingenieur wenigstens was wo ich
was zu sagen kann die sind alle so glücklich hier da war auch so ein fotograf in irgend so
einem daily und er hat gesagt jetzt dreht euch doch mal um und lacht und wir freuen uns so dass
wir haben tafel stehen dürfen und zeug drauf heften administration zentralen linux server
umgeben wenn ich glaube das muss man copy copy pasten software entwickler sich ab ok aber auch
gleich reingucken weil wir uns aber das war es für heute die website ist mega lahm die war das
mit first first time to render und sowas aber gucken wir erstmal hier an zentrale linux server
suze bis jetzt sah das doch gar nicht schlecht aus diese anzeige aber suze
weiterentwicklung unserer automatisierung aus ccd ansible puppet github wunderbar passt gut
zusammen beratung troubleshooting gemeinsam mit produkt auch vollkommen gut gut und passend dafür
monitoring performance optimierung unsere lebenssysteme ich singa ich weiß immer nicht
über das richtig aus elastic stack prometheus auch gute sachen mitgestalten von it projekten
das bringst du mit abgeschlossen studium informatik bezug ok erfahrung mit umgang linux
it security verständnis container orchestrierung docker kubernetes programmiersprachen shell python
ruby interesse an open source finde ich gut dass es drin steht gut dass eine gute stellenanzeige
die gefällt mir also gesagt ich bin ich auf der suche nach einem job kurz und knackig mit den
passenden stichpunkten drinnen natürlich könnte es immer noch ein bisschen geiler sein aber die
gehen in ordnung die finde ich gut ist natürlich die frage ob das gehalt passt home office wäre
auch noch eine interessante überwiegend mobilen arbeiten wunderbar ja klingt gut klingt nicht
schlecht guck mal die m hat sogar ein github account was haben die da so lisa lovely interface
das ist ein formen ui wenn die pappet formen ist glaube ich für pappet sort nach sternen
erinnere mich ein bisschen an meinen alten arbeitgeber die hatten auch formen und pappet
okay nicht so viel spannendes da okay dann widmen wir uns jetzt mal der digitalen revolution die
farben erinnert mich ein bisschen an das jetpack die jetbrains logos der hat schon mal richtig
hochkant notebook und noch ein kraft und was hat er offen das ist das hollywood was er im
hintergrund laufen hat näher da hat tatsächlich etwas was sinnvolles laufen glaube ich ja der
stuhl ist wirklich viel zu niedrig aber gut mein jeder wie er wie er will das ist hollywood was
erlaufen hat im hintergrund das ist hollywood hier ist c matrix das ist zur erklärung wer das
nicht kennt es gibt ein tool unter linux das nennt sich hollywood ich kann euch das mal ich kann euch
das mal zeigen das heißt hollywood weil das deine deinen terminal so aussehen lässt wie halt in
film wenn die event wenn sie am hacken sind pass mal auf ich will das nicht installiert haben weil
das ist 30 milliarden dependency ist deswegen ups war ich ein snapshot und resette den dann
gleich wieder dafür das ist das was der typ im hintergrund laufen hat kommen terminal kackzucker
ab bei das hat er im hintergrund laufen guckt da sieht man hier an c matrix und sowas ich glaube
ich habe es kaputt gemacht lustig ok snapshot wird und weg ist es wieder ok also lasst uns das
mal angucken finde ich schon mal sehr nah es gibt bei mir schon mal pluspunkte dass er hollywood im
hintergrund laufen hat vielleicht ist es auch nicht hollywood vielleicht ist es auch dieses das andere
tool es gibt auch ein konkurrenzprodukt dazu hier oben hat er github oder github vom logo
er geht lab oder so auf gut vorankommen mit prosos in ganz deutschland begleiten wir kommunen auf
dem ok das ist der grund warum das keiner machen will wir haben den grund sofort schon gefunden
da ist wahrscheinlich keiner bock drauf egal wie gut die firma ist als als lehrer dafür den
sub als komplett anbieter liefern wir lösung aus einer hand von der software bis hin zur beratung
um die digitale transformation in der kommunalen verwaltung da hat keiner bock drauf suchen wir
für für mehrere teams software entwickler sich scharf verstärkt unsere team in der geschäftsfelder
bauen und umwelt oder soziale sicherung in vollzeit mit arbeitsort im home office oder
in in härten im herzen des ruhrgebiets und komme voran beim marktführer für kommunale it lösung
das wird dein job du bist aktiv an der entwicklung pflege andere produkt beteiligt du stellst
hochwertige technische lösung auf basis fachliche anforderungen du unterstützt die product owner
innen bei der analyse und bearbeitung von anfragen mit software technischem hintergrund ist alles
sehr vage oder du arbeitest in einem scrum team du schreibst entwicklungs begleitende tests das
neue meta ist entwickler zu suchen die keine test schreiben weil ihre sachen immer gleich
funktionieren du entwickelst datenbank gestützte oracle mssql desktop anwendung auf ich glaube da
haben heute wenige dort net entwickler wirklich noch bock drauf auf wpf basis uralt anwendungen
zu pflegen das könnte natürlich auch sein dass das mit da rein spielt dass sich zu wenig leute
drauf bewerben du arbeitest in einer modernen entwicklungsumgebung abhängig vom jeweiligen
einsatzbereich bestehend aus rider sehr gut dort hat 4.8 hat keiner mehr bock drauf heute c++ 17
für masochisten svn ach du kacke geht gut in unit meinetwegen resharper ja wenn zwischen studio
ist du nutzt nach einsatzgebiet eine gut ausgestattete umgebung aus github oder team
city mit mehr als 100 warum gibt es da mehrere sachen das wünschen wir uns du bringst okay
du besitzt eine beruf okay unit test c++ wpf aber auch wpf du konntest bereits erste erfahrung
in github oder team city sammeln so denkst du vielleicht du passt zu uns wenn die folgenden
sätze auch von dir stammen können okay also chat wir überprüfen das jetzt mal ob ich passen würde
also würde würde würde ich diesen satz sagen qualität ist mir wichtig um diese
zu erreichen habe ich sowohl produkt und fachlichkeit als auch die prozesse und das
umfeld im blick okay ich würde es vielleicht nicht so sagen aber ich finde es ist gar nicht
so verkehrt so eine hohe produktqualität entsteht durch die zusammenarbeit aller
beteiligten am ganzen ergebnis was eine hohe produktqualität entsteht durch die
zusammenarbeit aller beteiligt einem ganzen ergebnis und kontinuierliche verbesserung
eine hohe produktqualität entsteht dadurch dass man high-q leute hat hauptsächlich leute mit
primes ab im wobblers twitch chat ja warum nicht ist auch nicht so verkehrt zusammenarbeit geht
nur mit gegenseitiger wertschätzung vertrauen offener ehrlicher kommunikation okay ja die
weiterentwicklung unserer produkte möchte ich aktiv mitgestalten und die den einbringen okay
mir ist eine gut dokumentierte und strukturierte architektur übersicht für unsere software
produkte wichtig ja aber habt ihr wahrscheinlich nicht zumindest liest sich das so als sind das
halt ganz viele legacy anwendungen gute gründe für prosatz prosos hohe eigenverantwortung kurze
entscheidungswege wertschätzungs viel raum zum ausprobieren flexibler arbeitszeit modelle mobil
das finde ich gut dass es direkt drin steht kill me to win gg danke für den sub huge
subscription homeoffice möglichkeit deutschlandweit okay unbefristet arbeitsvertrag attraktives
vergütungspaket umfassungsrücktritts anbauten zum orientierten ankommen also wahrscheinlich
ist der laden gar nicht schlecht irgendwie ich kann ich kann euch nicht sagen warum ja die
stelle anzeige haut mich jetzt auch nicht vom hocker aber ich glaube der laden ist gar nicht
schlecht das einzige was also warum also mal angenommen ich würde mich ich würde mich als
dortler entwickler dort bewerben ich kenne mich mit dort nicht ja ganz gut aus aber ich bin kein
hauptberuflicher anwendungsentwickler mike danke für den sub scroll noch mal ganz runter willst
du die personal managerin angucken oder was oder warum soll ich runter scrollen gehaltsach
also hier muss man seine gehaltsvorstellung angeben ok also ja die die website ist jetzt
jetzt nicht unbedingt die webseite ist vor allem langsam es fuck ja wo man jetzt ist es schnell
die ist richtig langsam leute also mit mit der webseite gewinnt ihr keinen blumentopf hier immer
guck mal die webseite lädt 6,5 sekunden krass alter das habe ich schon ewig schon mal gesehen
besteht aus das ist das eine webforms anwendung noch jQuery das wirkt sehr legacy mäßig also
seriously ich glaube das ist gar nicht schlecht irgendwie sagt mir das mein gefühl ich kann es
ich glaube ich glaube der laden ist gar nicht so übel diese sachen hier allerdings als modern
zu verkaufen ist halt schon ein bisschen bisschen wird ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es in dem fall
tatsächlich sogar besser ist weniger zu schreiben schreibt lieber die modernen sachen rein ich
meine ihr solltet die leute vielleicht nicht komplett sie beten wenn sie euch danach fragen
aber muss ich ja auch nicht schlechter darstellen als man letztendlich ist also ich würde dort
4.8 schon mal komplett rausschmeißen ich würde svn schon mal komplett rausschmeißen ich würde
drinnen lassen wischel studio und rider ob ihr jetzt ein unit verwendet und wie scharfer ist
wurscht geht rein c++ kann meinetwegen drin svn raus dort hat acht raus rider wischel studio
drin stehen lassen und vielleicht ein bisschen andere moderne sachen wenn ihr das habt wenn ihr
moderne wenn ihr moderne sachen habt wie höhenverstellbare schreibtische eine kantine
kinderbetreuung und was auch immer würde ich das auf jeden fall noch erwähnen aber schmeißt
schmeißt zumindest svn und dort net 4.8 raus und schreibt dort net core rein falls ihr dort net
core anwendungen habt wenn ihr halt keine dort net core anwendungen habt es halt dann weißt du
eigentlich schon was sich erwartet dann würde ich wahrscheinlich nur noch dort net schreiben
der anderen seite irgendwann müsste die leuten ja auch mal rein wein einschenken ja ist doch
für bewerber gut wenn sie denkt so wie das hier aktuell aussieht sieht es für mich aus als wurden
dort anwendungen erstellt 2008 und mehr oder weniger ja sind die halt immer noch da und du
musst dich um anwendung von 2008 kümmern so liest sich das für mich wpf ist halt auch nicht mehr
der hit also das ist so ein job wo ich mir vorstellen könnte den nimmt halt ein dort
net entwickler an der der sich denkt so eigentlich kein bock mehr mit etwas neuem zu beschäftigen in
drei jahren gehe ich in rente können wir noch machen was wahrscheinlich auch viele nicht schockt
ist dass es ihr um behörden zusammenarbeiten mit behörden und kommunale sachen geht wobei
das eigentlich ja gar kein problem ist ihr seid ja der dienstleister dafür ihr seid ja nichts von
also ihr seid ja schon ein ganz normales privates unternehmen was halt dienstleistungen anbietet
für kommunen oder oder nicht oder seid ihr irgend so einen wie nennt man das so einen abkömmeligen
von irgendeinem staatlichen ding dann ja dann ja da muss man es vielleicht ein bisschen besser
verkaufen dass man eben nichts wirklich hier öffentlicher kram ist sie sichere arbeitsplatz kann
man sicherlich auch noch mal reinschreiben schwierig also ich also vom gefühl her habe ich schon den
eindruck also ehrlich gesagt hauptsächlich nur wegen dem bild hier oben dass der typ hollywood
auffahrt auf seinen bildungskisten ja aber vom gefühl würde ich sagen dass er schlechter land
ist gar nicht übel ich weiß jetzt auch nicht wie man es ein bisschen besser verkaufen könnte
ich brauche einen neuen audio adapt ist wirklich so im arsch ja weil warte mal so das liegt glaube
ich nicht daran ich habe mich nicht bewegt gerade vielleicht habe ich auch wieder in obs zu viele
zu viele sachen offen das müsste ich müsste das halt hier mal mit schneiden ist es ist es jetzt
gerade aktuell leute ist es vielleicht wenn ich irgendwie im browser groß rum scrollen oder
reloade irgendwie sowas in der richtung jetzt ist nix top sagt sekunde vor aus die ja keine
ahnung was ich will wissen ob es an obs liegt oder an mikrofon selbst wahrscheinlich am mikrofon
selbst ich kann er mehr jetzt zu ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen so aus dem stehgreif wie gesagt ich
habe den eindruck der lande ist gar nicht schlecht da müsste das irgendwie ein bisschen bisschen
attraktiver verkaufen ja aktuell würde ich halt aktuell denke ich mir halt so okay ich bin dort
nette entwickler gehen fünf jahre in rente und sucht noch irgendwie was dann dann würde ich
mich auf sowas bewerben so nach dem motto das ist eine sichere sache für fünf jahre ich kann das
benutzen was ich schon seit 20 jahren benutze da war es ja okay da war es ja okay wir haben so nach
dem motto das ist eine sichere sache für fünf jahre ich kann das benutzen was ich schon seit
20 jahren benutze ist doch gar nix fünf jahre in rente und sucht doch hier hier fünf jahre in
rente und sucht doch irgendwas dann dann würde ich mich auf sowas bewerben so nach falsche
killen nähe das wäre dann dauerhaft aber das ist nicht jeden streamer ich glaube ich muss einfach
rebooten und dann ist es weg das ist das wird irgendein windows scheiß sein könnte ich wetten
vielleicht liegt es auch echt an meinem audio adapter an dem wird es also an meinem ach so
filmen will also am audio interface wird es nicht liegen neuer rechner fuck ja wird mal wieder zeit
geld auszugeben na gut ich hoffe es hat dir trotzdem ein bisschen geholfen wer war es denn
was mit weh am anfang weil mamo mir fällt gar nicht so wirklich mehr dazu ein kann es ja
nächste nächsten monat noch mal zeigen wenn sich was geupdated hat da gucken wir rein leute ich
muss jetzt ins bett bett geteilt müde schlafen das scheiße sind die haarisse im mainboard jetzt
zeigen sie sich langsam ich glaube wir brauchen mal wieder outro musik kann das
sein outro musik heute bis zum nächsten mal macht's gut